REGINA HERZLINGER: So the first step in this framework are the caveats.
Just watch out.
Second step is what am I?
What kind of innovation am I?
So in my many years of looking at this, I&#39;ve
categorized innovations into three types of innovations.
So one type is consumer facing.
It&#39;s audience is the consumer.
So drugs that sell in drugstores, they&#39;re consumer facing.
Something like a retail medical clinic, maybe a Minute Clinic where you live,
that&#39;s consumer facing.
This kind of innovation is saying to the customer I&#39;m quick, I&#39;m convenient,
I&#39;m cheap.
And you can reach me without any intermediary in the way.
Another kind of innovation, very different one,
is technology innovation.
Let&#39;s say somebody has a drug that can ameliorate hepatitis
or Crohn&#39;s disease or MS or AIDS.
That&#39;s technology.
This is a burst of science and the challenge
for this person is how do I commercialize it?
How do I make sure that it gets into the hands of the right people in a way that
still enables me to make a living?
Third kind of innovation, very different from the other two.
I call it an integrator.
This is a chain of something.
So the most ubiquitous kinds of integrators
are stores like McDonald&#39;s or hotels like the Hilton chain
or department stores like Walmart.
So what do these guys promise?
They&#39;re not promising quick, convenient like the consumer facing ones.
They certainly don&#39;t offer dazzling technology.
They&#39;re not curing AIDS or hepatitis or congestive heart failure.
So what are they doing?
They&#39;re saying we offer consistent products and services
at a relatively low price.
And the way we do this is we&#39;re a chain.
So if you&#39;ve got a lot of something, you can
develop metrics of how the work is done, you can measure how the work is done.
You have a lot of scale in a chain.
The economists call this economies of scale.
In other words, you can buy things more cheaply
because you&#39;re buying millions of whatever you&#39;re buying.
How many hundreds of millions of pounds of potatoes does McDonald&#39;s buy?
Well, certainly it&#39;s going to get a better buy per pound
than you and I might get if we go into our local supermarket.
So why do we have these categories of these three different kinds
of health care ventures?
Because analyzing their business model requires very different kinds
of elements.
And we&#39;ll go back to this in detail as we go into our cases.
But let me give you a simple example of this.
Let&#39;s say you&#39;re running a chain of retail medical clinics like Minute
Clinic.
What kind of CEO do you want for this?
Do you somebody who has a PhD In biotechnology?
I don&#39;t think so.
Do you want somebody who has a lot of experience
with running chains of manufacturing plants?
I don&#39;t think so either.
What you want is somebody who has a background in consumer facing ventures.
Somebody who knows how to cater to consumers
with the convenience that they want.
So one of the reasons to be very clear about the differences
among the three kinds of ventures is they
require different kinds of management.
The managers of a biotechnology companies
and the managers of a Minute Clinic, they&#39;ve
got to be very different kinds of people.
So, you know, lectures, they&#39;re so boring.
And we&#39;re going to get done with this soon.
We&#39;re going to get to case discussions where you&#39;ll do the talking
and I&#39;ll do the listening.
It&#39;s much more interesting.
People really remember when they talk.
They don&#39;t remember so much when somebody else talks.
Ever notice in a group, people say, well, what I said was,
they remember that very vividly.
What you said, not so much.
So let&#39;s take a case example of a venture
and let&#39;s try to classify what this venture is.
So let&#39;s take a doctor.
And he&#39;s kind of a computer geek doctor.
So he uses computers a lot and he has written
a program that can go through the voluminous medical literature
and answer questions that people want answers to.
Like, my doctor says I should have a pacemaker installed.
Very invasive procedure.
But if I don&#39;t have the pacemaker installed, she tells me I might die.
So what is it that the medical literature tells me
about the installation of pacemakers?
What are the long term consequences?
After all, I&#39;m going to have this machine sitting inside of me.
I&#39;m kind of worried about that.
What happens five, six years out?
Does it wear out?
Does it still keep functioning?
Does it do funny things, like does it go off erratically?
So this doctor&#39;s figured out a way of taking the huge medical literature,
it&#39;s beyond the ken of anybody.
In fact, one of the biggest health insurance
companies in the United States made a deal with IBM
that has a computer called Watson.
So Watson is legendary for having beat the all time Jeopardy!
champion because it can so easily analyze mountains and mountains of data
and come up with the right answer.
And they&#39;re trying to apply Watson for particular uses.
This guy&#39;s got a much more user friendly version of Watson.
He&#39;s tried it with a couple of his colleagues.
They say it&#39;s great.
He&#39;s tried it with his friends and family, they say it&#39;s fantastic.
This a typical venture.
Probably not a good idea to begin with, because he&#39;s
invested thousands of hours in writing this program without really
knowing who&#39;s going to use it or how it is that they are going to use it.
But bless his heart, he&#39;s done it.
So what kind of venture is this?
Is this consumer facing?
Is this like Minute Clinic?
Quick, convenient, easy?
I don&#39;t see it.
If you think about the kind of CEO you want for a consumer facing venture,
somebody who comes with a consumer marketing
background like the people in Procter and Gamble
or some of these legendary consumer marketing companies,
you want that person to head this venture?
I don&#39;t think so.
So is this a technology venture?
Not quite like getting a drug that will ameliorate the AIDS or hepatitis
or Crohn&#39;s disease.
Technology ventures, they take your breath away
because they have such novel solutions using science
to solving the problems of medicine.
That&#39;s where the PhDs and the propeller heads come around.
Even though he&#39;s a doc, I don&#39;t see it that way.
So we&#39;re left with one category.
It&#39;s kind of a strange category, is this an integrator venture?
In other words, does it enable health care
to be delivered in a cheaper and more consistent way?
Yeah it does.
Because if you search the medical literature
and you find answers to questions, you will get medical practice
that is more uniform and that follows what they call evidence based medicine.
So rather than some erratic application of medicine,
you&#39;ll get more standardized ways of doing things.
And when you get more standardized ways of doing things, you know what happens?
Errors go down.
When errors go down, quality goes up and costs go down.
So this is, believe it or not, this is an integrator venture.
Who&#39;s going to buy this thing?
Funny you should ask.
So in the United States and in many developed countries,
people are recognizing the problem with health care
delivery is that it&#39;s too fragmented.
Hundreds of thousands of doctors practicing
alone, thousands of hospitals, they don&#39;t talk to each other.
They each do their own thing.
They&#39;re all well meaning and most of them are phenomenally brilliant people,
but that&#39;s no way to run medicine.
So increasingly, there&#39;s a movement to integrate the delivery of care
in the United States.
So health care systems all over the world are terribly fragmented.
In the US, there are over 500,000 doctors who for a long time
have pretty much practiced medicine as they see fit to practice medicine.
Thousands of hospitals that have done the same.
Clinics, nursing homes, all very fragmented.
Some people who&#39;ve studied the outcomes of this health care system
say that this fragmentation is a real problem.
Because due to the lack of standardization
in the practice of medicine among all these thousands
and thousands of doctors, hospitals, clinics, nursing homes,
there is not one way of doing things.
Because there is not one way of doing things,
people make mistakes that might be avoided if they
adhere to more standardized protocols.
When they make mistakes, two things happen.
Quality goes down, costs go up.
So in the US and in other developed countries,
there is a movement to integrate these providers, to have systems of care
rather than one of, two of, five of doctors or hospitals providing care.
One form of this integration in the US is called the Accountable Care
Organizations.
These are systems and they consist of hospitals and doctors and nursing homes
and clinics and urgent care centers.
Essentially everything that you need if you need medical care.
And they provide it out of one system that&#39;s networked
and talks to each other and all the providers
know what everybody else is doing.
The Accountable Care Organizations, they&#39;re
called ACOs with their initials, they might
be very interested in this program.
After all, this program searches through the medical literature
and it comes up with what the medical literature has
found to be the best answer to a specific kind of problem.
In fact, I think they&#39;d be real interested in that.
And real interested for their providers.
So that&#39;s medical speak for their doctors,
their nurses, their therapists, all the great people who
are in the health care system.
And they might be even be interested for their patients.
So the patient i talked about earlier who
says you want to put a pacemaker in me, I want to know how this works,
how it works in the long term, what the positive side is,
what the negative side is.
OK.
So we&#39;ve got the ACO as a customer.
The ACO is an integrator and this medical program enables integration.
So what kind of person do we want to head this kind of new venture?
Hold that thought.
We&#39;ll come back to this question in a little while.
But before we even address this question,
we want to figure out whether this thing is viable or not.